on behalf of the European research group
I'd like to make literally a brief
statement
we have had a meeting this morning to
discuss the issue of the conservative
leadership
[Music]
we believe that we have one and
potentially two extremely strong
connections to be leader of the
conservative party
but as a group we were unable to
collectively endorse either candidate
however
having some of us having spoken to both
candidates potential candidates this
morning
they were equally adamant that they
would take if they became prime minister
a very robust line on the Northern
Ireland protocol
to and including if necessary
utilizing the parliament Act
to ensure that the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill reaches the statute
in addition
we should say that both of them were
very clear
that if either of them were to become
Prime Minister they are absolutely
determined to do everything they can to
unite the conservative party
and that the government that they would
lead in its formation and composition
would clearly reflect that aim
the ERG have resolved that whoever
becomes the prime minister of the United
Kingdom
be that tonight or on Friday we will
unite behind them and assist them in
seeking to unite the conservative party
that is the statement
we are willing to take a few very brief
questions but then on a fast-moving day
forgive us if there are a few other
things that we have to do Camilla was
first
membership in the grocery store sale
well the best way I can answer that is
that we did not endorse either candidate
we all know what the situation is if by
2 pm
penny mortens has not achieved a hundred
validated nominations
then Rishi sunak will effectively become
the prime minister so no no no
Camilla we all understand what the issue
is and what I've said is that we have
not endorsed either candidate now
we had a very good debate
I also had a number of text messages
from individuals who couldn't be here
because it's a Monday morning we
normally have our plenary on a Tuesday
evening when the house is sitting but it
was a 1922 committee that dictated a
very compressed timetable so we had a
very Lively debate but at the end of
that we could not come to a complete
agreement on whether to endorse one or
the other of the potential candidates so
I think it's better to be honest about
that Gary
we can trust the guarantee
is in a different place when he was in
Canada
at the end of the day Richie sunac is
more than capable of speaking for
himself so indeed I think he's Penny
Morton's what I can tell you is that
when a delegation of us went to see both
of them this morning they were both very
very clear I would say adamant in fact
that if either of them were to become
Prime Minister they would take a robust
position on the Northern Ireland
protocol up to and including invoking
the parliament act if that became
necessary I'm looking at my offices I
think that's a fair representation of
what they of what they both said anymore
any more than that you've got to you've
got to talk to them a couple more please
we
the phrase Red Line we just ask both
people what they believed in
um
let's just the other thing you cared
about was three percent on defense
we asked both candidates when we saw
them about defense the the answer to
your question is and we we Benchmark
that against three percent and the
answer is is that Rishi sunak did not
commit to three percent but said he was
determined if he were prime minister
that he would spend whatever was
necessary to keep the country safe
Penny mordant went slightly further she
said that her aim was to get to three
percent on defense but when economic
conditions would allow
so
on the on a general election my I'm
speaking personally here we had a
general election in 2015 we had one in
2017. we had one in 2019 even despite
the events of the last few weeks I'm not
convinced that the British public want
four general elections in six years now
one last one please then I think we're
done we're all we good
perhaps one of my other colleagues would
like to I don't want to hog it all
probably answering something slightly
different we what was a very complex 3D
chess game last week where we didn't
know where this was going to fall it's
now become very binary
are we going to evolve the members in
this process or not
and that is an issue where the ERG was
similarly split should members be
involved or not I tend to fall on the
basis that members should
if that gives you any indication as to
where some were thinking where others
weren't that isn't as cryptic as it
sounds it's very very binary but this
party is absolutely governable the ERG
has always supported Prime Ministers
perhaps bar one because that was a major
major constitutional issue and we did
come apart on that one but everyone
before and everyone after we have been
very very reliable and I see us as at
times the Victorian guard of whatever
prime minister we are loyal and we all
agreed report whoever is going to be the
president yes we should as Catherine is
right to remind me we did reiterate that
at the end of this process whoever
becomes the Prime Minister we will
attempt to give that person our voice
thank you very much indeed for your time
thank you